[Music]
all right let's talk about asian
american
issues
i hate asian americans yeah
yeah don't say that [ __ ]
i'm on your side i love asian americans
what about you america no you know why i
say
ah what issue do you have against asian
americans i'm tired of hearing hurtful
[ __ ]
because it makes me want to go out and
um retaliate
and i'm not i'm trying to be a good boy
i'm trying to be
a peaceful samurai i'm tired of cutting
people samurai joe
true yes there are there are a lot of uh
a lot of bad things happening happening
to the asian american community
these days and um i mean but that's i
feel like that's the case for any
community yeah and uh it's it's just a
bad bad world
uh this story here focuses on a chinese
student who was going to a flight school
in texas and uh to be specific denton
texas which is uh i was right by your
place yeah i used to actually go to
school too
at a unt in denton so oh really
wait we went i actually spoke at denton
oh yeah
oh cool yeah last year yeah in spring oh
[ __ ] okay cool
was that unt i don't know oh
denton university i don't think there's
a denton university of
university no it was in denton though
okay it's gotta be university of north
texas
maybe like denton middle school yeah oh
middle school is good
without hairstyle yeah but yeah so this
uh aviation academy also known as the us
aviation group it's like the most
generic name for any flight school
they learn how to fly but apparently
it's like the top flight school in
all of the country and what they do here
is
a lot of different international
airlines send their
pilots to this specific school to get
trained
and to you know pass as pilots or
whatever and so a lot of chinese
airlines are sending their pilots to
this school
to get trained oh wow yeah so the jack
which is actually great
um i think you know you know you know
more than merrier you know i think you
know passing on the information having
you know uh you know pilots have more of
a standardized
you know uh education be great but
within the school there seems to be a
lot of uh discrimination
oh no that sucks why uh like we don't
want no
ching chong's unheard yeah it seems that
way let me show you a photo and this is
this photo kind of
uh you know it kind of illustrates quite
a bit
uh here we go
what does that say it's a lot of photos
of uh
chinese pilots students and then up here
says
speak english only at all times
and then all these photos are of them
holding a sign that says
i don't speak english like i am supposed
to
what the and this is just posted out in
the hallways of the school
damn that's [ __ ] up and that that says
a lot that says a lot right
is that by the school or is it by like
some students that are just
sure students i think student body i
think is doing this
but it's but it's got the us aviation
academy logo
on this printer you know on the paper
students could also make that too
i don't know for sure for sure but it's
like it's definitely within the confines
of the school you know
they're not american citizens and
they're international students right yes
these are international students
i don't think they understand that
whoever made that poster they think
they're
they're chinese immigrants and they're
like you should assimilate and it's also
too it's like
why do they always want you to speak
english like why
like why did i always say that yeah it's
entitlement oh it makes me so it's not
like they want to hang out with these
guys anyway
you know what's funny though it's they
don't even know the law like we don't
even have an official language
yeah idiots we don't oh well isn't that
law
like there's no law saying english
english is not the official language of
america no
interesting and there is no official
language of america dude this [ __ ]
reminds me of my old job my
my old boss shoe so i would be like you
need to speak
english here we're not in mexico anymore
so stop speaking spanish we'd be on our
[ __ ] lunch break
speaking spanish because all of my
co-workers were what you do in your
private time what happened to
privacy what happened to [ __ ]
individual liberty what happened to that
[ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] i'm so glad i don't work
under these chinese people probably
don't even if they can't speak it they
probably don't even know what they're
holding yeah just there's one
they're like she's like oh thank you
hold this real quick we're gonna take a
photo so they're probably like smiling
each other
because yeah hold on it was a blank
piece of paper and they photoshopped
over it oh i thought they that dude did
they probably
they could have got they how did i zoom
in more
oh just with the mouse pad mousepad two
fingers and then pinch it out yeah like
it's a vagina's
what it's not working like an iphone
collab
the old teacher at the school hey
student come help me i feel that all the
time
wait you have to double click and then
do this and then do this okay
do it like i said see if they if they
made them hold the signs with that
already on there
their faces are blurred out obviously to
protect their identities and whatnot
but yeah that's that's that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's that's that's so okay so i see
what they did they could have got a sign
that said ching
chong and had them hold it up yeah
that's so sad that's so they probably
just think okay i'll hold it
see that's that's not cool that's that's
do we know who put up these posters is
there cctv footage and all these
[ __ ] gonna reprimand it
uh no currently no it's this ongoing
investigation i haven't gotten to the
saddest part of it
there's worse yeah so i'll probably get
away with it
so uh any suit filed on september 21st
uh parents of this particular student
accuse the school of discriminatory
practices that target chinese students
uh and then some of these uh
discriminatory prac
discriminatory practices include
chinese-only
physical tasks and humiliating
punishments for those who violate its
english-only speaking policies like
hazing pretty much hazing
exactly and so some of the things that
they were forced to do
was um [ __ ] where to go and this is from
the school
school the school has a policy that yes
no no i think other students that's for
sure other students
yeah it doesn't clearly state who it's
from but
it sounds like i would assume it's from
students
i don't know that's for sure probably
other students yeah but like some of the
some of the things that they had to do
um in publicized images violators were
seen holding signs uh one photo shows
the students 14 hour daily schedule
that included holding doors open for the
staff cleaning scuff marks off the
floors and cleaning toilets at night and
this is all based
on the chinese only physical test that
sounds like
it's from the school that is from the
school yeah
forcing these kids to do these
punishments that's what it sounds like
yeah and the saddest part of this all is
and this is why there's an investigation
going on
within this now is that uh the this
family that is filing the lawsuit
their son yang yang 21 was found dead
on the morning of april 16 2019 is
dormitory from hanging
oh my gosh yeah it's pretty sad it's uh
and and and this is the school statement
the school's uh statement give me some
backhanded [ __ ] the school statement is
you should have learned english [ __ ]
yeah yeah
yeah so uh some backhanded [ __ ] chief
executive officer has since refused to
take responsibility for the death
uh rejecting allegation of
discrimination he claims that yang's
poor mental health resulted from his own
poor
academic performance in his words mr yan
was a student who did not meet the faa
safety and quality standards we then
this is the
empathy this is the school yeah the
school requested permission to cease mr
yan's
uh training from the from his airline in
october 2018 from the chinese airline
right
they initially denied our request and we
asked that they reconsidered they still
deny the request and so additional
training was provided to mr yan
uh he continued to perform below and
acceptable
be below an acceptable level and and
fell further and further behind his
classmates now
as we look back we all wish that the
original request would have been
accepted
mr yan would be safely back home in
china right now
and that was their official statement
wow so they're blaming
his poor performance in school for the
reason why
well i mean for lawsuit reasons they're
going to [ __ ] dodge it of course
but that just makes people pee like
they're what that probably means
that's probably proof that they're the
ones with all these rules you know
in regards to the photo they didn't they
didn't comment on the photo you know on
that and the
incriminating photo of them holding the
signs and all that this guy adds
becoming a pilot also requires natural
talent too in our judgment mr yan did
not possess the natural
ability to become a pilot we are deeply
saddened that he was not allowed to
return in china to pursue another career
what about all these like tasks that
they're making students
did not mention it it did not so it's
it's them then it's the school yeah it's
totally it's totally just cool yeah or
regardless you know what i mean it's
like it's like a fraternity right
like an official chapter fraternity at a
different university may not operate the
same way that chapter
uh will operate at a different
university but
in that chapter if those people are
[ __ ] doing [ __ ] up things like
that whole chapter that name that
fraternity is the one that's gonna be
held accountable you know what i'm
saying not just the people
they're representing something so it's
like this whole [ __ ] school
what happened what happens next like
what happens so the mom the parents are
now and this is the photo of the parents
i'll show you a photo of this
i hope this family gets cashed out
student thing like are there any
students that are coming out and being
like
a lot of other chinese pilots a lot of
chinese pilots are coming out
saying they're backing the evidence of
the that photo
and saying like yeah there's a lot of
hazing going on so
these are the parents uh says let me see
my son
my dead son for one last time that is so
[ __ ] sad
and then that's the photo of the kid oh
man happy birthday he was getting some
hot pot too
yes he was getting that damn that's so
sad
but yeah so it's ongoing um the mom has
now relocated to north texas
and she's trying to get to the bottom of
it and trying to find out more of what
happened
yeah so yeah well i don't know well
maybe we'll cover the
you know whatever comes of this
hopefully you know we'll find out soon
that's so crazy the fact that the school
was completely like
took no responsibility for anything yeah
not even like not even tried to say
there was the students like
they they completely ignored everything
so to me that's like
it feels like the school is kind of
guilty a little bit because it's not
like they
these are the five kids that [ __ ] up
exactly like we're expelling all five of
them
it's almost like they're trying to like
put up this like veil of like oh i don't
know
well i think because the problem
with our system i think
is if they do that they're admitting to
guilt which means that they can be
liable for a lawsuit and lose
because in the public platform they
actually said yeah we [ __ ] up
now they could do a class action lawsuit
and pretty much
completely destroy the school and take
millions and millions and millions i
want to know what the non-chinese
students have to say about this
like did they win they didn't provide
any interviews from them
right now they noticed that these
chinese students had to do like
[ __ ] open the doors for other people
like all that [ __ ] does it seem like
it
so another chinese student said he he
said that
um in his words i have personally
observed students from other countries
including cambodia africa and mexico so
like it's very international at this
school
uh they're these people are speaking in
their native language in front of the us
uh staff and they were never punished
the way chinese people were punished
so it seems like there is a target a
deliberate yeah a target
uh so how long ago was this this is
pre-coven so that's kind of interesting
because
you would think as i'm reading i'm like
i'm like thinking this is well maybe
it's kovid related but
he passed it's your guy's fault for
bringing cocaine
right he passed away in april 2019. oh
so it's well before the covet stuff
happened so so this flight school
is it's it's it's pretty like um
diverse in the way where a lot of
different people from different
countries come here
to learn how to be a pilot and then they
go back to
like whether it's asia or africa or
whatever airline
station yeah and they become pilots of
those companies
so they're used to the staff is used to
a very
diverse group of people yeah but it's
the u.s
staff that is infringing on on the
chinese students for some reason
wow they probably see them as easy
targets and they're just going to keep
yeah and that's kind of like the case i
feel like with a lot of stuff that's
happening like in new york city
and you know in like in san francisco
bay area it seems like
a lot of people are taking advantage of
asians and specifically chinese people
being kind of
smaller whatever yeah and then
don't think that they're gonna fight
back or whatever i don't condone
violence and i don't condone retaliation
but i do think sometimes if fools try to
bully you you should just punch them in
the face one time i disagree with you
you have to retaliate
without condoning all these things
that's so like when we can get in
trouble for legal issues
yeah yeah yeah you're right so don't
listen to me i was joking
i don't could do that either he does
condone it but also like
sometimes you have to uh you know
be fortunate you should stand up for you
sometimes you gotta pop someone in the
nose real quick you can't be an easy
target like
no i'm not saying you are an easy target
i'm just saying like you have to always
make it you know
a little difficult for yourself you have
to make
you can't even this is just in the
context of a bully right
yeah someone's bullying you like your
wife or something yeah like my wife
i have to i gotta [ __ ] you have to
body slam her
what's up suplex yeah you have to show
her who's boss
yeah i ain't cooking dinner tonight what
the [ __ ] and i get in her face like this
yeah
and then you make out and then she looks
at me and i go sorry my best
but because i did this initial action
she thought about it and she kind of was
like i think twice next time yeah
exactly
happy anniversary and then you really
get in trouble you got to pick your
battles though you got to pick your
battles you can't just do it over
everything yeah like you got to know
when to do it
there has to be a breaking point you
have to have boundaries it's called
boundaries okay guys
set those boundaries so when someone
infringes on that
then you have the like yeah yeah these
are my blankets exactly
so
[Music]
you